another thing that dr bryant is not  allowed to do with the foundation  attempting to disprove 343 to 343 it's a  horrible idea agents are still studying  the resulting paperweight supposedly so  heavy that 343 should not be able to  lift it for context while debate around  the truth of the matter still rages  among foundation staff and in our  comment sections  scp-343 is a reality warping anomaly  that refers to itself as god believed to  be omnipresent omniscient and omnipotent  a classic thought experiment on the  possibility of this is whether god is  capable of creating an object they  themselves couldn't lift resulting in a  paradox or in this case an  astronomically heavy paperweight that  the scp foundation now needs to deal  with thanks jack